do you have shower advice in your book
this is interesting yep yep what your
shower advice yeah go ahead well I mean
we talk about brushing you know brushing
your teeth in the shower here's the
thing I don't regularly let's recap yeah
because we talked about this before I
don't regularly brush my teeth in the
shower I just I do if I'm in a hurry now
I do happen to be in a hurry a lot often
so it happens often so Heaven is that's
your that's fine because that's where
you are in the world that's where I'm at
that's my choice on the whole other side
where I find it to be gross and I don't
do it and I think there's another
mention of like maybe washing your legs
in the shower like get all the way you
know don't just leave your ankles out
like but wait when you're washing up
here it does wash
down that's how you see just different
different approaches to life it's fine
well I mean I'm also I guess I shave my
legs almost every day in the shower so
I'm kind of doing it anyway but like do
you pee in the shower these are real
hard
[Music]
question
no I would lie if I said I had never
done
it but I try I almost every time in the
shower that's awesome good I'm glad that
you're open enough to say that no but no
but here it's you can't help it it's
that it goes back to that childhood
sleepover you know they put your hand in
the hot water sometimes you be cuz it's
hot water the hot water hits your body
not every time but like if I got to go
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm
not against it I've not never done it
it's I've done it you but like when I do
do it I always feel so
ashamed you know what I feel I feel
productive I feel productive I feel like
I've knocked a lot out I'm brushing my
teeth I'm doing everything at once you
know what I'm always in a hurry I feel
you I I want to stay in bed as long as
possible and then roll out out yeah yeah
and just be ready yeah and be ready so
are you like 30 minutes be 45 minutes of
ready o no I get ready in seven minutes
oh yeah quick one yeah that's why people
I just was in Montana and this little
girl her mom was like this is Kelly clar
she's like no it
ain't and and I was like you're
absolutely right Kelly Clarks is on TV
this is Kelly Brienne that's right yeah
I look very different
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home